i should be tweeting about jeff epstein
all the time
and you're afraid well it's awesome i
mean i said it
in the public yeah many times why is it
we don't ask where the
records are from villard house where
where are the financial records where
the sec filings
yeah where are the questions on on the
record to the intelligence
uh agencies was he known to be part of
the intelligence community
so so we're we're not interested in
asking questions like am i gonna die
as a result of asking the question was
jeff epstein part of the intelligence
community
of any nation is there a reason we're
not asking about the financial records
of the supposed hedge fund that he
didn't run
just like the wuhan lab okay how do we
get to the core of the jeffrey epstein
the the truth behind jeffrey epstein in
a sense
i mean there's there's some things that
are just like useless conspiracy
theories around it even if they're true
there's some things they get i hate to
say it you're not gonna like it
look at the 1971 media pennsylvania
break-in of the citizens committee to
investigate the fbi
those kids and by the way they weren't
all kids
did what had to be done they broke in
they broke the law it was an incredible
act of civil disobedience
and god blessed judy feingold for taking
to her
she was going to take to her grave that
she'd been part of this like the coolest
thing of all time
they didn't say anything for forever so
civil disobedience
i mean you have to we are founded on
civil disobedience civil disobedience is
incredibly
you screw it up and you're just a vandal
you screw it up you're a hooligan
yeah those those cats were so
disciplined it's an art form and it was
an art
form and they risked everything they
were willing to pay
with their freedom those
are the sorts of people who earned the
right by putting themselves at risk i
would not
do this i am not volunteering to break
into
anything i think it was uh william
davidon
who was a student of murray gelman and a
physics professor at haverford
who corralled these people and led this
effort
and right now what we need is somebody
to blow the lid off of what is
controlling everything
we have i i'm happy
to hear that it's a system of incentive
structures that it's a system of
selective pressures i'm happy to find
out that it's emergent
i'm happy to find that it's partially
directed by our own intelligence
community
i'm happy to hear that in fact we've
been penetrated
by north korea iran china and russia
but i need to know why people aren't
like the firebombing of the courthouse
in portland oregon has no
explanation and somehow this is normal
this is not normal to any human being
we have video that people don't believe
and you know i come back to the shaggy
defense
of it wasn't me you know it
was like um
you remember that song shaggy yeah
wasn't me caught you uh
banging on the encounter on the couch
yeah exactly it wasn't me
it wasn't me he says but his friend says
well
your strategy makes no sense at all this
is what msnbc is doing
you dropped him from the graphic it
wasn't me it wasn't me you came up with
another yang
it wasn't me i will never see msnbc
the same again
you